ya hemos establecido que estas tres
integrales valen cero para estas
condiciones que tenemos del lado derecho
ahora vamos a seguir y por supuesto
siempre recuerda que nuestro objetivo es
poder calcular series de furia y hallar
los coeficientes que acompañan a cada
función trigonométricas muy bien
entonces en este vídeo vamos a calcular
la integral de 0 a 2 pi del producto de
senos es decir seno de emt por el seno
de nt dt verdad y esto será igual a 0
justo en el caso cuando m sea distinto
de n es decir tomemos digamos números
entre los distintos verdad y cuando m
sea distinto de menos en es decir
tampoco puede ser el inverso aditivo
verdad y por supuesto aquí vamos a poner
que m n sean enteros verdad aquí estos
son enteros y entonces también cabría la
posibilidad de que m y n sean iguales
verdad
en el caso en que me llene sean iguales
pues tendremos la integral de 0 a 2 pi
del seno de mt por el seno de mt
entonces eso es el seno al cuadrado de
mt verdad por supuesto esto es con
respecto a de verdad y éste nos va a dar
un valor de pi muy bien entonces aquí en
realidad lo que nos va a interesar es el
caso en que tomemos coeficientes
positivos verdad porque en series de
fury eso lo vamos a tomar en estos casos
muy bien entonces vamos a resolver este
problema vamos a tratar de resolver este
problema
y simplemente vamos a bajar un poco esto
muy bien entonces vamos a tratar de
hacer esto muy bien entonces lo primero
que vamos a hacer como siempre es tratar
de expresar esto de otra forma
utilizando identidades trigonométricas
muy bien entonces aquí por ejemplo lo
que podemos hacer es bueno es reescribir
la integral de cero a dos pi y el seno
de m por t por el seno de n por te lo
podemos ver como una diferencia de
cosenos y otra vez si no te acuerdas de
esto puedes revisar en la página de khan
academy algunas identidades
trigonométricas verdad pero esto en
esencia lo podemos escribir como un
medio que multiplica al coseno de m - n
que multiplica t - el coseno de m más n
que multiplica
muy bien y todo esto va a ser integrado
vamos a dejarlo con el mismo color con
respecto a té muy bien ahora bien lo que
nosotros podemos hacer es distribuir
este producto verdad él un medio
multiplicaría a estos dos cosenos y
tenemos la integral de una diferencia de
verdad en realidad eso sería la
diferencia de las integrales entonces lo
que tendríamos sería un medio que
multiplica a la integral de 0 a 2 y
delko seno del coseno de m - n por t y
aquí vamos a integrar con respecto a t y
luego restamos que sería un medio por la
integral verdad la integral de 0 a 2 pi
del coseno
el coseno de m más deporte
en el porte de té muy bien entonces
fíjense muy bien que en este punto
verdad aquí lo que tenemos es que m cn
no es cero y m
n tampoco es cero porque justamente
estamos suponiendo que m no es n así que
este es un número entero no nulo vamos a
ponerlo así esto es un entero no nulo es
decir no es cero verdad justamente
porque me es distinto de n y aquí
tendremos que m n también es un entero
no nulo un entero no nulo justamente
porque m no es menos n entonces bajo
estas condiciones
nosotros sabemos verdad desde antes que
en la integral del coseno de un número
entero no nulo verdad por t desde cero a
dos pi es cero verdad entonces ambas
integrales esta integral será cero esta
otra integral también vale cero y en
este caso toda la integral pues vale
cero verdad porque simplemente
multiplicamos por un medio
pero todo eso vale 0 verdad entonces
aquí ya tenemos está esta primera
afirmación verdad esta primera
afirmación vamos a ver qué pasa con el
caso en el que m es igual a n y para eso
voy a borrar todo esto vamos a borrar
todo esto todo esto vamos a borrarlo y
dejarlo más o menos limpio y lo voy a
dejar justamente hasta aquí entonces si
nosotros evaluamos el caso en que m es
igual a n verdad en este caso si m es
igual a n pues justamente tenemos el
caso de la integral verde verdad pero
bueno si m es igual a n pues m n sigue
siendo un entero no nulo verdad estoy
todavía es un entero no nulo vamos a
escribirlo entero
nulo y entonces está integral vale 0 sin
embargo la integral del lado izquierdo
pues m
n vale 0 verdad y entonces ya no es
válido nuestro resultado que teníamos
antes pero en realidad es muy fácil
verdad aquí lo que vamos a tener es que
esto vale 0 verdad y el coseno de 0 por
tesco seno de 0 y eso vale todo 1 muy
bien entonces en esencia con lo que nos
quedamos es con lo siguiente tendremos
un medio que multiplica a la integral
desde cero hasta dos y de la constante 1
dt
dt muy bien y esto va que será igual
bueno esto será un medio que multiplica
a la anti derivada de uno y nosotros
sabemos que la anti derivada de uno es
de verdad y esto va evaluado desde cero
a dos p entonces esto por supuesto será
igual a un medio que multiplica
multiplica a 2 p 2 p - 0 entonces de
hecho sólo lo vamos a dejar como 2 pi y
la mitad de 2 pues es justamente pi y
ese es el valor de nuestra integral para
el caso en el que me es igual a n y en
cuyo caso se escribe como la integral
desde 0 a 2 pide seno al cuadrado mt con
respecto a verdad entonces el resultado
speed entonces en resumen cuando m es
igual a n tenemos que la expresión verde
es equivalente a la que teníamos
anteriormente cuando m es igual a n y en
este caso la integral vale